okay for the world cup winner for duda
this not the ideal result because he's
still fighting for qualification but
eric has proved on the board at least
that he should be getting the draw so
that would be a fair result i think
okay maybe just while we're waiting
maybe if i
just show why the position will end in a
draw anyway yeah uh maybe we can keep an
eye on the players just to see
why this uh see what happens with them
but in this position if eric is given
the opportunity to carry on the game
then he will play rook takes pawn the
black will recapture a pawn it's two
pawns versus two pawns level material
and if duda wants the draw he will just
play queen takes rook and this is what
ivanka mentioned earlier he'll simplify
everything giving up the queen
temporarily but after the rook comes
across pinning the queen we will see
everything get hooved off queen takes
rook king takes and just not enough
material left to checkmate dead draw and
apparently a draw has been accepted so
it is a draw you guys this game is a
draw a dramatic game
ending with a draw a
very nice gesture from young christoph
duda